bonsoir jean louis passarieu merci
d'être avec nous alors vous vous faites
partie de ces élus en colère on vient de
le dire les élus qui ont pas payé un
lourd tribut campagne premier tour des
municipales plusieurs d'entre eux sont
morts dont hot et d'autres ont été
gravement atteints vous même vous avez
eu le virus mais plutôt heureusement de
manière bénigne ce n'est pas le cas de
votre directeur de cabinet exactement
donc bonsoir à tous mondiale temps de
campagne a été touché en fait par le
virus donc c'est quelqu'un qui est plus
âgée que moi donc il avait 69 ans elle a
été hospitalisée pendant une dizaine de
jours à la suite de sa contamination
probablement le jour de l'élection
municipale en tout cas alors on a
beaucoup parlé de ces élus effectivement
dans plusieurs régions on déplore la
mort de certains élus qui correspondent
effectivement à ce premier tour des
municipales on aimerait bien savoir ce
qui s'est passé ce jour là parce que le
gouvernement avait tout de même donné
ces prescriptions est ce qu'on n'a pas
pu les suivre comment ça s'est passé
concrètement sur le terrain
alors moi je vais parler vraiment du cas
digne sur scène donc c'est vrai que à
partir dans certains bureaux de vote à
partir d'une certaine heure les gants
n'était plus disponible par exemple gels
hydroalcooliques lui est resté assez
bien disponible mais en tout cas les
gestes barrières étaient parfois mal mal
respectés en tout cas c'était assez
difficile de les respecter il y avait
beaucoup de monde dans les bureaux de
vote et je veux dire notamment au niveau
du dépouillement ou finalement on est
sur des tables de quatre avec deux
personnes de chaque côté il n'y a pas
cette distance d'un mètre finalement
entre les personnes donc je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup d'assesseurs qui ont été
contaminés qu'aussi bien à vigneux
qu'ailleurs via ce biais là et c'est
vrai que les gestes barrière vu la
logistique du vote et vu la mise en
place était compliquée à appliquer en
tout cas ce ce jour là en plus du manque
de masques évidemment je veux dire nous
on n'avait par exemple pas du tout de
masques pour pour se protéger ce jour là
donc on avait vraiment l'impression
d'être quelques parents en première
ligne face au virus
ce jour là en tout cas avec le recul
vous pensez que c'est une faute du
gouvernement c'est une photo auquel le
gouvernement
devra répondre plus tard la tenue de ce
premier tour des élections municipales
où vous faites partie de ces gens qui
disent écoutez il ne savait pas
finalement ils l'ont fait en toute bonne
foi on ne pensant pas à mal alors c'est
c'est compliqué de vous répondre mais je
pense que le comme l'a dit jean luc
mélenchon le lait sont soumis n'ont pas
été vraiment consulter pour prendre
cette décision avant avant la tenue des
bureaux de vote
nous on a quand même décidé de
s'impliquer parce que pur respect pour
nos militants et par respect aussi pour
la campagne qu'on avait engagé alors je
pense que oui c'est une responsabilité
que le gouvernement à laquelle devra
répondre et je pense que ça sera le
l'enjeu aussi dans les prochaines
semaines de répondre sur ce sujet là
comme sur le sujet des manques de
masques et du manque de tests au 6e aux
ports aux navires us mais enfin exposé
autant de personnes dans un stade en un
nombre de villes dans toute la france
alors que la veille les restaurants et
tous les lieux de filaments de loisirs
avait été fermé il ya quand même un peu
de quelque part quelque chose qu'on ne
comprend pas pourquoi nous envoyer voter
alors que le confinement à l'aide
décidée quelques jours après que les
restaurants étaient déjà fermés en fait
vous ne le comprenez vraiment pas honte
pour vous le gouvernement avait tout
simplement une arrière pensée politique
je ne générera pas jusque là puisque je
pense pas que c'est les élections
étaient vraiment en des bonnes élections
pour pour aller à l'om du coup je vais
pas je n'accuserai pas d'avoir ses
arrière pensées politiques
mais en tout cas je pense qu'il ya eu un
manque de prévision en tout cas une
cacophonie qu'on a retrouvés souvent à
plusieurs étapes de la crise
que ce soit sur la livraison des masques
sur le gel sur les l'était sur les
protocoles et c'est vrai qu'on a une
espèce de cacophonie entre aller voter
mais n'allez pas au restaurant donc je
pense que beaucoup de gens n'ont pas
compris ça quand on sait la proximité
qu'on peut avoir dans un bureau de vote
que ce soit dans la queue que ce soit au
moment du vote que ce soit lors du
dépouillement
vous parliez des masques à des tests
emmanuel macron annoncé
un premier déconfinement partir du 11
mai avec une réouverture partielle des
écoles vous dans votre commune est ce
que vous êtes prêts alors oui oui je
pense aujourd'hui moi je fais je suis
conseiller municipal d'opposition mais
les informations que les remontées qu'on
a sont que des l'ensemble des
équipements de protection seront seront
disponibles pour les agents donc du coup
de la municipalité
maintenant on n'a pas encore
l'information sur les agents scolaires
notamment sur les professeurs donc du
coup mais aussi les atsem les ash qui
elles pourront retourner
finalement au travail peut être sans
protection donc c'est une vraie c'est
une vraie volonté en tout cas pour moi
de surveiller la bonne mise en place de
ceux de ce déconfinement avec un
véritable plan que ce soit sur les
masques aussi et sur les masses pour les
pour les scolaires notamment et pour les
personnes travaillent dans le scolaire
est également sur les tests qui devront
être mises en place je pense dès le 11
mai en fait comment réagissent les
personnels justement des écoles dans
votre commune et sont plutôt confiants
il vous faut et nous font confiance
alors je voulais vous en parler parce
que ma mère en fait travail en tant que
ash du coup elle est aussi quelqu'un de
gai dans la classe un peu à risque
aujourd'hui
donc ils sont un peu inquiets mais ils
sont prêts à retourner à retourner
travailler parce que les enfants le les
enfants leur manque tout simplement
aussi ils ont conscience aussi que cette
longue période d'inactivité scolaire
augmente les inégalités entre justement
les plus riches et les plus pauvres dans
l'accès donc je pense que le service
public a confiance dans dans ses
représentants encore pour repartir mais
ils veulent vraiment exercice le message
que font passer cia les protéger quand
on sait que des enfants soient ou
simplement en maternelle ou une école
municipale
c'est dans une école maternelle ou
pardon en école primaire
c'est difficile de leur faire accepter
les gestes barrière donc ils veulent y
aller mais protéger avec des masques
voie avec des gants et avoir un
protocole vraiment pour être rassurés
pour pouvoir bien bien mettre en place
leur leurs services publics et leur
l'orée du défunt l'éducation de nos
enfants
merci beaucoup jean louis a pas sérieux
conseillers avaient
sipa la france insoumise à vigneux sur
seine un tour seulement
merci beaucoup